[Music]
you
lambu Johnny CEO of Maajid off the team
welcome to Stanford into the
industrialist allama thank you
tell us about marginal for his business
today in 2020 we like to define our
business as being to define much that
routine as being in the business of
creating great moments for everyone
every day it's our vision and this is
something that continues to be relevant
we do that through providing a modern
lifestyle to our customers and that
ranges from providing spaces where
people meet and and experience each
other through shopping malls hotel
residential developments as well as
grocery retail leisure entertainment
cinemas ski slopes in those snow parks
and ski slopes consumer finance and
other business of the like digital is
increasingly impacting all parts of your
business from shopping to movie
entertainment how is marginal for time
dealing with these changes and how
consumers are shopping and consuming
media well you know we it's a great
opportunity because what technology
allows us to do today was just
unthinkable she is back and digital is
another dimension another another medium
to interact with our customers so we're
getting smarter we're getting better at
that and we are infusing a digital and
technological dimension into the
relationship that you have with the
customer through the what we call today
the only channel dimension that is
something that in itself is allows us to
better understand our customer become
more customers century than average and
also be connected to our customers to
longer periods of time so we understand
the customer better and you are able to
provide to the customer what they
actually want at the time that they want
it in the way they want it this is
something that all organizations have to
be able to do by being fit for purpose
by being technologically I would say
enabled and I think this is a condition
for success going forward the company
has a very large footprint across the
Middle East and North Africa how do you
think about recruiting and people
development in that part of the world
two things one is basically grooming
your future leadership from within so
this is something that's extremely
important we at measure them are very
very committed to do that through our
Leadership Institute the school of
analytics and technology of school of
great
and etc etc and this is something that
we continue to do on they day in day out
the other thing that's extremely
important is through the work that you
do to build our international reputation
is to be able to attract global talent
or talent of global Sacher but also to
promote regional talent of global search
this is why the standards that you apply
to ourselves what the bar where we put
the bar and what good looks like and our
continuous reinvestment our commitment
to our people it's something that allows
us to be an organization that's
interesting the stretches people but
those that provides opportunities for
people to grow you've been the CEO now
for over five years what's been the
biggest surprise since you took over the
business and have you seen it change in
your time in running the organization
I've always heard that I would say the
consumer moves the faster markets move
slower and companies moves even slower
it's always a surprise to see how slow
we are as human beings to accept the
change that we actually lead when when
we when we as I mean the same people
when we are the customers so the same
person who's the customer leads change
and when this person comes behind the
desk suddenly we become much slower
adopting and adapting to it continues to
be a great surprise surprise to me as a
leader what do you try to do to keep
your organization moving quickly in a
rapidly changing world I would say a
number of things you have to and that's
what I try to do continuously one is you
shouldn't settle for anything that's
nothing is good enough you have to be
able to at the same time the acknowledge
and recognize the progress that you're
doing but continue to push the power
forward I think a leader has also to
have the ability to create a burning
platform even though it may not come
across as obvious because short of being
able to continue to transform change
adapt and continue to be fit for purpose
I think it's it's very difficult to
continue to succeed in this world
conversations I've had with you and with
your leadership team over the last
several months it's been very
interesting to hear how
see the business going forward over the
next five to ten years how do you think
the company looks in 2030 when we're
sitting back here at Stanford and we're
doing our third case on the company what
will the organization be like well I
hope in 2030 we'll be doing our tenth
case of the company so I hope the
company will continue to be interesting
enough and have enough content to
stimulate people but I think and I hope
and I'm working tirelessly as well as
the team against having an organization
that will become by 2030 even more
globally relevant I think that comes as
a result of scale so scaling up our
business is something that is extremely
important in a world of trillion-dollar
companies you can't anymore be relevant
if you don't have scale because if you
don't have scale you can't compete so if
you want to be in the conversation you
have to have scheduled a final question
for you what's the biggest thing that
keeps you up at night when you think
about the company that's challenges and
what are you doing about it to in order
to make sure that you'll be able to
future proof for the future you know the
it's it's the same question I would say
it's how do you make sure that you are
able to reinvent ourselves every day how
do you go every day and continue to be
able to reinvent ourselves how do we get
people aligned and basically being able
to confront that challenge and to turn
it into an opportunity the biggest
opportunity we have is that of
reinventing ourselves it's also the
biggest challenge I think organizations
that are able to crack that problem are
organization that will always be
future-proof amber Johnny's CEO of
Maserati
welcome back to Stanford and thank you
so much for coming thank you for having
me
you